and finally new rule now that the blue
wall of silence is finally cracking
Republicans must tell us if we'll ever
see a crack in the red wall of silence
yeah that's the solid front Republicans
put on whenever Trump does something
outrageous as with last week's tear
gassing of protesters here's NBC's KC
hunt trying to get senators to comment
on that was what the president did last
night the right thing to do was that the
right thing to do was clearing the
protesters and abuse of power you don't
have any comment on what happened at the
White House last night are you concerned
at all about what happened at the White
House last night sorry do you think what
we saw last night at the White House was
what we saw at the White House last
night an abuse of power one thing you
got to say about Republicans they're
tight in 2016 three Republican
Congressman Steve Scalise and past and
present Majority Leader's Paul Ryan and
Kevin McCarthy were caught on tape in
what they believe was a private
conversation admitting they thought
Trump was on Putin's payroll really they
laugh about it and then Ryan says no
leaks right this is how we know we're a
real family here yeah that's how they
are what happens in the underground
volcano layer stays in the underground
volcano layer this is how we know we're
family he says a crime family sure but a
family what I want to know now is is
there another conversation Republicans
have had in private where they agreed
that there was something Trump could do
that would make them stop him of course
they would never tell us because being
Republican is all about never breaking
ranks but amongst themselves is there a
safe word you know to say for it is
right don't lie you freaks you know a
safe word
is an agreed-upon specific word that
people engaging in rough sex used to let
their partner know they're not playing
anymore and they really want it to stop
so it has to be an offbeat word that
would never come up during actual sex
for example Melania uses I'm coming but
for most garden-variety freaks
it's a word like you know I don't know
pineapple you say pineapple so that way
when the dominatrix is choking you you
don't have to say stop you [ __ ] you're
killing me and she doesn't have to say
wait really stop or pretend stop and I
would like to think Republicans have
that with Donald Trump because any
dominatrix will tell you most of her
customers are successful older white
guys with power and authority they know
they don't really deserve in other words
they're Republicans and in Washington
they're all in thrall to mistress
khofifah and his 50 shades of orange the
way Lindsey Graham acts around trumpets
like something out of a pornhub clip
titled slave abused by fat daddy and I
want to know if there is something fat
daddy can do that will make his
Republican bottoms tap out and say
pineapple if he asked me five years ago
when this nonsense all began what it
would be I would have thought it was the
very first thing Mexicans are rapists
but no or the next month when he said
McCain wasn't a war hero but it was soon
evident that the line was not going to
be drawn on matters of behavior mocking
the handicapped bragging about your dick
at debates grabbing [ __ ] all good
then once in office it became apparent
the line would also not be drawn at what
we call norms you know practice is so
universally agreed upon to be the right
thing to do that we never thought we
needed to codify them into law releasing
your taxes not putting family members in
the cabinet having press briefings
siding with America
instead of Russians and then we moved on
to breaking actual laws not answering
subpoenas using campaign funds for hush
money to mistresses withholding foreign
aid to allies and domestic aid to states
for personal reasons so we know what
won't make republicans say pineapple and
I doubt when he makes Ivanka the defense
secretary or starts poisoning
journalists or literally shoot someone
on Fifth Avenue that that would do it
either but now now that we're at the
Julius Caesar moment here where the
Republic becomes a dictatorship with
real talk about calling the military
into the streets and elections that
might not count because they're rigged
is that the stuff that will finally make
Republicans say I'll do anything for
love but I won't do that if you've got a
safe word Republicans you better use it
soon because democracy is about to stop
breathing
you